♪ ♪
>> Kimberly: WELCOME BACK.
NEW SHAKE-UP FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
CABINET.
REX TILLERSON FIRED AS SECRETARY
OF STATE.
CIA DIRECTOR MIKE POMPEO HAS
BEEN NAMED TO REPLACE HIM.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT ON THE
STUNNING NEWS EARLIER.
>> REX AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
WE GOT ALONG ACTUALLY QUITE WELL
BUT WE DISAGREED ON THINGS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE IRAN DEAL,
I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
I GUESS HE FELT IT WAS OKAY.
I WANTED TO EITHER BREAK IT OR
DO SOMETHING.
AND HE FELT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY.
SO WE WERE NOT REALLY THINKING
THE SAME.
WITH MIKE POMPEO, WE HAVE A
SIMILAR THOUGHT PROCESS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO GO VERY
WELL.
REX IS A VERY GOOD MAN.
I LIKE REX A LOT.
>> Kimberly: THIS AFTERNOON
TILLERSON APPEARED BEFORE
MICROPHONES.
>> I WANT TO GIVE RECOGNITION TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND OUR
PARTNERS FOR A FEW OF THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
ALL OF US WANT TO LEAVE THIS
PLACE IS A BETTER PLACE FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION.
I WILL NOT RETURN TO PRIVATE
LIFE AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN.
AS A PROUD AMERICAN, PROUD OF
THE OPPORTUNITY I'VE HAD TO
SERVE MY COUNTRY.
GOD BLESS ALL OF YOU.
GOD BLESS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
GOD BLESS AMERICA.
>> Kimberly: DANA, WHAT DID
YOU MAKE OF THAT?
HE WANTED TO DO THE STATEMENT.
IT WAS GOOD HE WAS ALLOWED TO DO
THAT.
>> Dana: I THINK SO.
THE TIMELINE IS ALWAYS
INTERESTING, THE STORY FOR
WASHINGTON, D.C.
GOT A CALL APPARENTLY WHILE HE
WAS OVERSEAS FROM GENERAL JOHN
KELLY FROM THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
OF STAFF SAYING THIS IS COMING.
TILLERSON CUT HIS TRIP TO AFRICA
SHORT.
LANDED AT 4:00 A.M., FOUND OUT
HE WAS FIRED FOR SURE AT
9:00 A.M., SPEAKS TO THE
PRESIDENT AT NOON.
WHEN HE COMES TO THE PODIUM, IT
WAS A MOST LIKE HE WAS
RELUCTANT.
HE WAS SOMEONE WHO DIDN'T WANT
TO BE IN WASHINGTON.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO BE PART OF IT.
HE DIDN'T LIKE THE WHOLE ASPECT
OF IT.
AND THEN AS HE IS SPEAKING, YOU
START TO REALIZE MAYBE HE WAS
REALLY SORT OF STARTING TO
REALLY RESPECT THE WORK, THE
CAREER FOREIGN OFFICIALS.
HE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THEM.
HE HAD ONE FATAL FLAW.
HE HAD LOST THE CONFIDENCE OF
THE PRESIDENT, AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD, ONCE YOU
SEE THERE MIGHT BE DAYLIGHT
BETWEEN A SECRETARY OF STATE
UNDER PRESIDENT, THAT'S IT.
YOU HAVE TO GO.
SO THERE WILL BE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION NOW AS MIKE POMPEO
FROM THE CIA COMES OVER TO
STATE DEPARTMENT.
HE AND THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE
TO SHOW, AND I THINK THAT WELL,
A UNITED FRONT FROM THE GET-GO.
>> Kimberly: JESSICA MIKE
POMPEO HAD BEEN RUMORED TO BE UP
FOR THE JOB AND WANTED THE JOB
WAY BACK.
THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION.
DIDN'T REALLY COME AS A SURPRISE
DIDN'T REALLY COME AS A SURPRIS
SURPRISE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALWAYS
EXPRESSED A CONFIDENCE AND VERY
SIMILAR VIEWPOINT AS POMPEO,
SOMEONE HE COULD RELATE TO AND
TRUSTED.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE ALWAYS
JAILED IN THE BRIEFINGS THEY'VE
HAD.
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE HAPPY.
HE IS HAWKISH ABOUT RUSSIA, MORE
SO THAN REX TILLERSON.
AND I AGREE WITH DANA.
THERE WAS MORE THAN JUST A
LITTLE DAYLIGHT.
THERE WAS A LOT OF DAYLIGHT WHEN
IT CAME TO THE PARIS CLIMATE
DEAL, IRAN SANCTIONS, MOVING THE
EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM.
THEY UNDERCUT EACH OTHER
PUBLICLY WITH THE
CHARLOTTESVILLE SITUATION AND
AGAIN ON THE NORTH KOREA
NEGOTIATIONS.
WE REMEMBER THE MORON COMMENTS.
HE HAS A GREAT PATRIOT AND A
GREAT MAN AND A GREAT
BUSINESSMAN AND A GREAT LEADER.
BUT THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE GREAT
LEADERSHIP AT STATE.
I LOVE THIS WOMAN.
I BELIEVE HER NAME IS GINA GINA
HASPEL.
SHE DIDN'T DESIGN -- PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT INTERROGATION.
SHE IS GOING TO BE TERRIFIC.
IT'S A REAL HISTORIC MOMENT FOR
A WOMAN TO LEAD THE AGENCY.
>> Greg: I THINK SHE SHOULD BE
PROUD OF WHAT SHE DID.
SHE HAS TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT A
LOT OF HER CRITICS DON'T HAVE TO
MAKE.
SHE ANSWERED THE CALL.
THAT CALL FORCES YOU TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT COULD PUT YOU IN
JAIL.
THE THING IS, IF YOU ARE FACED
WITH A POTENTIAL TERROR ATTACK
THAT COULD KILL THOUSANDS AND
THEY SAY BUT IF YOU DO THIS, YOU
GO TO JAIL.
IF YOU FOLLOW THAT ORDER, YOU
ARE WRONG.
IF YOU FOLLOW THE ORDER THAT
PUTS YOU IN JAIL, THAT MAKES YOU
A HERO.
AND THEY SAVE LIVES.
I THINK SHE IS A HERO.
IF SHE WAS A TV CHARACTER, SHE
WOULD BE A HERO.
A WOMAN RUNNING A BLACK       BA
A WOMAN RUNNING A BLACK       BK
A WOMAN RUNNING A BLACK       BO
A WOMAN RUNNING A BLACK       BS
A WOMAN RUNNING A BLACK       B.
AS FOR TILLERSON, DO NOT GO ON
SO LIBERTY BIG BROTHER.
WHEN HE WAS HIRED, WE LOVED
REX TILLERSON.
HE WAS AN ADULT.
HE WAS THE BUSINESSMAN WHO WAS
GOING TO COME IN AND PLAY IT
STRAIGHT.
I GUESS FOR ME I'M A LITTLE BIT
SAD THE WAY IT HANDLED.
I KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE HE WAS
FIRED ON TWITTER.
WE KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE BUT I
DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU WERE HIRED BY TRUMP,
DON'T BRING A LOT OF KNICKKNACKS
AND PHOTOS AND DIPLOMAS TO YOUR
OFFICE.
YOU NOT GOING TO BE VERY LONG.
FOR SOME REASON, I DO FEEL
REX TILLERSON SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HANDLED BETTER BECAUSE HE'S
OBVIOUSLY A VERY GOOD MAN.
>> Kimberly: YEAH.
CONDOLEEZZA RICE SUPPORTED HIM
AS WELL.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT
SENATOR MENENDEZ GOT IT RIGHT
WHEN HE SAID THIS IS MORE
EVIDENCE OF COMMANDER CHAOS,
SPEAKING OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I AM WATCHING TILLERSON AND
WAITING FOR HIM TO SAY SOMETHING
WONDERFUL ABOUT HAVING SERVED
WITH HONOR TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE NEVER MENTIONS TRUMP.
HE SAYS WE ARE ALL HONORED TO BE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE, TAKEN AN
OATH TO SERVE THE CONSTITUTION.
NOT A WORD ABOUT TRUMP.
NOT A WORD ABOUT HIS EXPERIENCE
WITH TRUMP.
>> Kimberly: HE GOT FIRED.
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS WORSE
THAN FIRED.
THE WAY HE WAS FIRED, SO
DISRESPECTFUL.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE LEFT THE
ADMINISTRATION WITHIN THE LAST
FEW DAYS?
HARD TO REMEMBER THAT GARY COHN
WAS JUST LAST WEEK.
THEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON AT
STATE, THE MORALITIES TERRIBLE.
HE WAS BREAKING DOWN THE MORALE
AT STATE, NOT FEELING         FL